When your schedule seems endlessly long, simplify it.
Concentrate on the really important things and delegate less important tasks if someone else can do them.
This may even halve your "to do list."
Set a limit on your working hours.
If you work more than nine hours, set a nine-hour limit.
Likewise, if you work eight hours, mentally try to have a six-hour limit.
Do the most important duties first, and the rest of the day will seem a lot easier,...
...rather than doing bits and pieces throughout the day.
It saves tons of time if you do all your emails in one go, do the paperwork and make all phone calls together.
Avoid unimportant meetings and, equally, avoid long conversations that are unproductive.
While interaction with co-workers is important,...
...you could be spending this time getting your tasks done and spending time with your family.
Finally, learn to say "No."
You may not want to disappoint someone asking for help,...
...but by agreeing to a task, you may have bitten off more than you can chew.